[Musik]
hallo ihr Lieben wir machen heute ein
richtig leckeres snowback Dessert aus
nur sieben einfachen Zutaten das ganze
Rezept ist no bake und es werden
Butterkeks vanillepuddingschnitten ich
stehe jetzt direkt am Herd und mache den
Vanillepudding und ich schreibe euch wie
immer die ganz genauen Mengenangaben
hier unten in die Infobox dann könnt ihr
das einfach screenshotten einkaufen
gehen und Nachmachen so ich gebe jetzt
hier meine Milch in den Topf hat es noch
ausgeschaltet dann gebe ich hier schon
den Zucker mit rein dann kann er sich da
auch gut drin auflösen und da kommt dann
Speisestärke hinzu einfach damit es fest
wird natürlich und die allerwichtigste
Zutaten in diesem Rezept ist
Vanilleextrakt weil nur so bekommen wir
den Geschmack
und dann nehme ich natürlich meins das
ist natürlich alkoholfrei es ist halal
und es schmeckt extrem lecker das ist
richtig richtig intensiv ich sag auch
immer macht den blind Test weil ich das
so überzeugt von bin und dann rühre ich
das hier einmal um und wenn alles
Klümpchen frei ist dann erst den Herd
einschalten und dann unter ständigem
Rühren einmal aufkochen und ein dicken
lassen und dann werde ich es umfüllen
mit Folie bedecken und ausklingen lassen
[Musik]
so während der Pudding jetzt gerade
auskühlt kann ich schon mal die weiteren
Schritte angehen und zwar ganz easy
einfach Sahne aufschlagen da ist es
natürlich am allerbesten wenn die Sahne
ganz kalt ist und frisch aus dem
Kühlschrank kommt die Schüssel sollte
jetzt auch nicht unbedingt warm sein
also nicht warm abspülen und dann
benutzen sonst schlägt die Sahne auch
nicht auf ich benutze kein Sahnefest
weil wir haben ja schon Stärke im
Pudding und das reicht mir um das Ganze
gleich fest zu bekommen das heißt hier
einfach nur aufschlagen und dann haben
wir hier nur noch Quark damit passiert
jetzt erstmal gar nichts und das war's
so der Pudding ist jetzt vollständig
abgekühlt und das ist auch ganz wichtig
bevor wir jetzt weitermachen weil
lauwarm könnt ihr den nicht weiter
verarbeiten und jetzt einmal die Folie
runter nehmen und jetzt nehme ich viel
wieder mein Handrührgerät ihr könnt auch
ein Schneebesen nehmen aber der Trick
ist jetzt einfach den Pudding noch mal
für 30 Sekunden richtig schön
geschmeidig zu rühren
[Musik]
so anschließend den Quark auch kurz mit
unterrühren wirklich nur so 15 bis 20
Sekunden das reicht schon und jetzt
nehmen wir uns einen Teigschaber und
heben die steif geschlagene Sahne unter
und das ist so eine Masse die wird nach
der Kühlzeit auch noch mal richtig schön
fest also sehr angenehm fest der cremig
und dadurch dass wir jetzt eben hier
auch das Bindemittel haben im Pudding
braucht man wie gesagt kein Sahnefest
oder sonstiges der Quark wird auch schön
fest nach der Kühlzeit aber wir müssen
das ganze jetzt noch Schichten ich habe
mir heute übrigens Kakao Kekse genommen
die hatte ich einfach noch so einen
Schrank und wenn ihr mögt könnt ihr auch
einfach Butterkekse nehmen oder diese
richtig dunklen Kakao Kekse da geht
eigentlich alles alles was ihr da habt
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt mein Backrahmen direkt
auf die Tortenplatte gelegt einfach
damit ich nicht mehr Umstürzen muss das
gestaltet sich nämlich ein bisschen
schwierig weil die Kekse sehr weich
werden und das coole ist wenn jetzt ein
Backrahmen verwendet so ein bisschen zu
viel wenn jetzt einnehmen könnt ihr das
einfach so eng spannen wie die Kekse
auch liegen also das wird dann einfach
perfekt und ihr habt dann keinen
irgendwie Überschuss oder so oder
irgendwie Maße die nicht passen so ich
gebe das jetzt noch mal zusammen also es
ist ja norwegische von anderes sehr
leckeres Rezept den scheint ja immer aus
und als nächstes einfach nur ein
bisschen Milch mit dem Pinsel auf die
Kekse geben das hat den Grund dass die
Stärke ja die ganze Creme so ein
bisschen abbindet es wird Feuchtigkeit
so ein bisschen austreten und die Kekse
saugen das auch so ein bisschen auf aber
gibt auf jeden Fall ein bisschen Milch
einfach drüber damit später auch die
Kekse schön weich werden dann könnt ihr
so richtig schön mit der Gabel dadurch
und daher mache ich das jetzt noch mit
dem nicht wir machen jetzt auch Kaffee
verwenden auch geil aber ich bleibe
heute bei mir nicht
[Musik]
so ich bin jetzt ganz oben angekommen
und schließe mit einer keksschicht ab
die jetzt auch noch mal so ein bisschen
mit Milch für pinselt wird und dann
kommt das Ganze für mindestens sechs
Stunden in die Kühlung also in den
Kühlschrank das ist echt wichtig dass
ihr da so ein bisschen Geduld habt aber
zurzeit z.B kann man das ja auch morgens
machen und dann ist es abente ready oder
man macht es einfach am Vortag für den
nächsten Tag in meinem Fall werde ich
das jetzt einfach einen ganzen Tag beim
ruhen lassen und dann mache ich morgen
den Test bei euch
[Musik]
also ich muss sagen wenn man sich
wirklich Zeit nimmt das zu kühlen dann
wird alles so soft ihr braucht nicht mal
eine Gabel ich schaue für mich jetzt
dadurch
zu wenig und deswegen habe ich zwei aber
ganz ehrlich wenn ihr abends so voll
seid oder ihr habt noch irgendwie
Früchte dazu oder irgendwas anderes dazu
dann geht er auch so ein so eine Kekse
ich habe die irgendwann mal ich weiß
auch nicht
so lange gefahren also können alle
möglichen oh das ist gleitet da so
perfekt durch aber ich finde schon man
sollte nicht irgendeine nehmen
die Möglichkeit habt holt wirklich man
Kakao Keks das sieht ja auch optisch
schöner aus für mich mehr Begeisterung
in dem Sinne gemacht
[Musik]
aber es schmeckt echt gut gefühlt
Anleitung halbe Stunde 40 Minuten
Kühlzeiten hat man ohne Ende aber man
muss ja nicht da stehen und so sitzen
vom Kühlschrank aber Nüsse endlich mal
fertig ich finde es richtig geil ich bin
begeistert Alter so ich wünsche euch
jetzt viel Spaß beim Nachmachen gönnt
euch diese leckeren Schnitten und dann
sehen wir uns auch beim nächsten Rezept
tschüss
[Musik]